i hate coming here hey peter remember me
tall good looking blonde hair blue eyes
button nose long time time
he's no comedian but he does kill in
nursing homes
[Applause]
[Music]
it's official unlike joe biden at 8 p.m
crime is up how do i know this
cnn reported it i'll give you time to
regain consciousness
yes the official network of zoom call
actually got something right cnn where
the n
stands for never mind so the story was
on their website
now it could have been a russian hacker
but it came out on a saturday
when people are watching sports playing
with their kids or replacing their bong
water
a shout out to steve ducey according to
their website a crime wave occurred in
2020 stretched into 2021 in democrat-run
cities
in nyc homicide spiked 14 percent
chicago 33 percent
la 36 percent memphis saw a jump in a
hundred plus killings
chicago endured a record 18 homicides in
one day
cities where defunding police was pushed
got hit the hardest
the good news most of the defund savings
went to gunshot related health care
again this is from cnn on a website
on a saturday meanwhile when the actual
crime was taking place
what was cnn saying in prime time you
must remember this
democratic cities are in chaos right now
is this what you want from joe biden and
they're going to take your country away
and they're taking down the statues and
crime is rising oh my gosh it's so
bad and again defunding police it's like
like mick jagger's face that has not
aged well
and what was lemon's response to real
crime data
well he did what any real honest
reporter would do
he went to dinner if you watch
a certain state tv and you listen to
conservative media you would think that
you know entire cities are just you know
enrolled in
fights and fires and whatever we went
out had a great dinner
in new york city tonight people actually
walked up to us and said thank you for
i watch you every night i can't believe
they thought they had to do a double
take at us actually
hanging out not seeing us on the tv
screen but new york city was not
you know hellscape was it oh dawn they
did a double take because they couldn't
believe you would wear mom jeans to an
applebee's
but judging by his ratings it's always
shocking when he's recognized
just so you know as he said all that
people were still being killed across
the country
so why mock the truth because it exposed
their own support
of violence and please show me where it
says that protests are supposed to be
polite
and peaceful because i can show you that
outraged citizens
are the ones who have made america what
she is and led to any major milestone
actually it's in the constitution
jackass but expecting
expecting chris to read is like
expecting his brother to keep his hands
off the help
look smart people knew that getting rid
of police and justifying looting and
property destruction
would lead to chaos but the media
refused to say so because it ruined
their narrative
and made them complicit in death but hey
maybe the death was mostly peaceful
so instead of focusing on the crime wave
they energized the protests which forced
police
to shift officers from neighborhoods
plagued by crime to babysitting
purple-haired overweight undergrads
i mean check out the mug shots of those
spoiled white
rioters most of whom look like members
of a boarding school av
club they enjoyed playing terrorism
tourism
knowing they'd safely go home to the
burbs when they finished burning down
the cities
now that's privilege and remember while
you watch those screaming petulant
creeps
shout out to stoic police somewhere
across town a bodega was being robbed or
burned
because officials reduced prison
populations to prevent inmates from
getting coveted
innocent citizens were attacked by
violent thugs who were either released
earlier and
just never detained overcrowded court
systems postponed the justice system
altogether
as even the dumbest thugs realized
accountability for their actions no
longer existed
turns out covet has been the best thing
to happen to criminals since democrats
welcome to clown world violent criminals
released so they won't get coveted
and business owners arrested for trying
to keep the lights on
the ferguson effect made it worse where
police pull back on policing because
they knew if they
even tried to do their job they would
lose their job or go to jail
this along with low police morale
boosted crime rates in cities with
already high rates of crime
meaning cities with a large minority
population once again the people of the
woke pretend to help
they end up hurting and the clowns
leading this phony crusade get ratings
and raises
an emmy nomination can't be far off so
where are we now in the middle of the
chovin trial or chovin
yeah i think that's his name what
happens if that outcome
doesn't go the way the media planned and
hoped for
the expectations are that the cop is
found guilty of murder
but are you sure that's going to happen
if not what happens
then remember the riots and the looting
from last year
it'll be back except it'll be way worse
the media just set the table for more
ungodly mayhem
i just hope it doesn't ruin don lemon's
dinner
let's welcome tonight's guest
if smiles were deadly she would be a
serial killer
outnumbered co-host and host of crimes
that changed america
on fox nation emily compagno
he's the nfl safety who doesn't need a
safe space
former nfl player jack brewer
and he knows where the bodies are buried
because he put them there
former cia operative and portman square
group what the hell is that
ceo mike baker
yes and she's five foot two in heels and
five foot four without hosting sincerely
cat
on fox nation cat tim
that is a hell of a scream back there
lady i want to hear more of that i don't
know what portman square is mike but i'm
not going to ask
all right jack i have a feeling you used
to do cnn
a lot and you're probably not allowed on
there anymore can i ask why
they kicked me off so now i'm here with
you brother
why were you kicked off because you know
don didn't like me calling president
trump the first black president
he didn't like that oh donny boyd didn't
like that a lot of people didn't like
that but you know what i said it
because what he did for my people
was unlike what we're seeing today and i
think the world is
is understanding why i made that
statement yeah that took uh
it took falls to say it now what do you
what do you um
why do you think the media is
downplaying this dramatic rise in crime
when you know it is actually hurting
minority communities most
they have no choice because you know
they're the arm of of
the left and so uh when you look at
these cities you got to look deeper
because they don't want to solve the
issues that are taking place in these
inner cities because you have to admit
the fact that you have a spike in places
like central baltimore you have a 200
increase in shootings can you imagine
having to be a single mom
poor underserved the democrats are
telling you that they're
for you but yeah you got to walk outside
and take your kids down streets that
people are getting shot i mean these are
babies getting shot nowadays
it's ridiculous and and so hopefully
you know cnn has to face
the fact that the narrative that they're
portraying are killing these babies
and if we continue to be loud the louder
we are
the more they're going to have to face
the true music and they're going to have
to go into these communities and
actually put programs in place that are
going to stop this mess from happening
yeah
you know uh mike uh welcome back thank
you very much
lovely set by the way why thank you it's
been a while you're a red-eye
original yeah um yeah back in the day it
was back in the day yeah you're in um
you're in your early 70s now 80s i just
i just turned 80.
and you formed a new organization after
killing off all of your partners
and burying them in a trailer park
somewhere in idaho yeah
i retired the diligence name we still
got warehouses full of diligent swag
yes thanks to wag
some people call it human skin yeah but
we
rebranded as as you kindly pointed out
mike mike you were in the c.i.a you
understand the criminal mind you
understand
uh law and order um what's going on
can this be stopped or are we doomed
well we're doomed
okay thank you thanks emily everyone
drive safely good night
uh you know look part of it is
look the media would be covering the
rise in crime
uh the rise in violence you know in a
much more
aggressive manner if many of the cities
were run by republicans
it's just it's all the points about the
narrative and that's
it doesn't matter what the story is kids
in cages right for four years it was
kids in cages now
we don't want to talk about that even
though we have more kids but now it's
called
facilities right and biden isn't trump
and biden's kind and so
it's a different story now they're
comfort suites yeah now they're comfort
suites exactly
and so look if you you you can't
discount the impact of of covet
obviously during the past year
on on the impact of the
violence and the rising rates absolutely
but if you also combine that with
defunding the police
yes if you police less you have more
crime
there's just that that's a correlation i
think most logical people would agree
with
nobody wants that either it's if you
listen to the media
there's these two sides that are never
going to agree and there's this one side
that wants to get rid of all the police
and if you if you don't then you're
racist and there's this other side that
thinks
cops are completely perfect uh but
really
last summer when obviously when you know
tensions were the highest the most
things were on fire
gallup did a poll about this and most
americans want including 81
of black americans want the same level
or more
of a police presence in their
neighborhoods but 94
of americans think that there should be
some or a lot of
police reform so we all that's a huge
number of people who actually agree on
this but nobody will let us
agree and and get along you can if you
agree
you the the the networks don't get
clicks
disagreement is what drives an audience
because
because negative i mean they're doing
studies negative stories
uh are people more interested i know
this for myself
emily on a very rare occasion somebody
will say something mean to me on twitter
i guess i can't imagine what that would
be like
meanwhile i get millions of fans that
tell me that they love me
and i just ignore them and i chase down
the person that insults me
and i say why don't you love me yeah
why don't you let me it's like i ignore
everybody else and that's because humans
have a weird
a weird evolutionary desire to look and
identify the negativity and that is kind
of what's driving this
totally off the topic emily it's good to
see you by the way it's okay we're out
of time
[Laughter]
you uh what do you what's your take on
all this as a lawyer
and a former defense attorney am i right
you're right thank you i've only known
her for yeah you've still been on the
show
nine million times who are you again
well look i mean i think even even more
than that i'm from the west coast
and i see that the cities are managing
that
rise in violence differently so look 63
out of 66 of the largest police
jurisdictions in the country saw a huge
spike in one of the major violent crime
areas right robbery rape murder etc
and let's look at la versus portland so
la after gutting the police budget by
150 million because of calls for
defunding the police
they just refunded it but we're so sorry
okay got it let's put it back into the
police and they actually included some
reform and then look at portland
the mayor asked for a 2 million one-time
infusion
and that included reform too it included
costs for an independent community
committee
uh to sort of oversee things whatever
the whole city council unanimously voted
against it and that all comes down to
narrative my family lives in portland
and has businesses outside of portland
who's speaking for them yeah
who's speaking to protect the small
business owners and you're you're it's a
crime family
but i love it it's like i mean
they're in waste management through
waste management john levin said his
internet was great and it was not a
hellscape
like you read that on yelp for a
restaurant not a hell escape
5 stars i don't believe he ever don
lemon ever went out to dinner no
i don't believe he ever went out to
dinner well no one said they watched him
every night
no yes exactly no one comes up to don
lemon at a restaurant